Rob here with the GS news update we've  got the latest news on borrowers  upcoming RPG dragon age inquisition  today barware released a trailer giving  us a glimpse of the story and dragon age  inquisition you play as the Inquisitor  the lone survivor of a cataclysmic event  that killed thousands you along with  your company must put an end to the  demons terrorizing the land the game  will launch october seven for ps3 ps4  xbox 360 xbox one and pc october seventh  is shaping up to be a big day for gaming  releases as the lure the Rings game  middle-earth shadow of Mordor as well as  alien isolation are set to release that  day for more on Dragon Age check out our  just published interview with the  executive producer of the game mark Dara  titled balancing freedom and story in  dragon age inquisition and for all of  your sword wielding magic casting dragon  slaying news check out gamespot com